- Narrator: Odds are you are
surrounded by nose-pickers.
It's true, one study found
that 91% of adults admitted
to picking their nose regularly.
So chances are you've probably mined
for some juicy nose nuggets yourself.
But maybe you didn't stop there.
Maybe you ate those boogers, too.
And it turns out that
slimy snack could hurt more
than just your social standing.
Let's take a closer look
at that booger, shall we?
It's mostly made out of water,
gel-like proteins that give
it that gooey consistency,
and special immune proteins
that fight off germs.
Those immune proteins
are especially useful,
because boogers are teeming
with harmful viruses like influenza.
And actually that's the whole point.
Boogers serve as your
body's frontline defense
against invading germs.
When you breathe in, you're
not just inhaling air.
You're also taking in
bacteria, viruses and dirt.
All those nasty things
get trapped by a layer
of sticky snot that line your nostrils.
It's like flypaper for the flu.
And as you continue to breathe,
air hardens the mucus into a solid booger,
a gooey prison cell for
all your ensnared enemies.
Now normally you can get rid
of that bacteria-ridden ball
either when you sneeze or blow your nose.
But if you for some reason
decide to eat it instead,
it stands to reason that
you're putting yourself
at risk of infection,
because as your body digests the booger,
it can release those harmful
pathogens into your system.
Now some people claim
that eating your boogers
can strengthen your immune
system by training your body
to recognize and attack invading microbes.
But sorry to say, there is
zero scientific evidence
to support any health benefits
from eating your boogers, zero, zilch.
And besides whether or not
you decide to eat them,
just getting a hold of your
boogers can be dangerous.
For example, scratching
up the inside of your nose
opens the door for a nasty bacteria
that lurks under your fingernails,
Staphylococcus aureus, or staph.
A 2006 study found that
nose-pickers were more likely
to have staph in their nose
than those who abstain.
And that's a big problem,
since staph can cause serious abscesses,
or pus-filled pockets inside
your nose and on your face.
Even worse, if you keep picking,
you could actually puncture your septum.
In one case, a 53 year old woman
managed to carve a hole
right through her sinus.
And if that sinus becomes
infected badly enough,
it can erode your skull,
leaving the door open
for bacteria to march
right into your brain.
But to be fair, these
are extreme scenarios.
One time probably won't hurt you,
but when it comes down to it,
next time you feel the urge
to mine for green gold,
just grab a tissue, man.
(blows nose)